wer teutone ist wahrscheinlich der
größte fleischfresser aller zeiten
gleich nachdem terex natürlich und dann
dann ist vielleicht auch noch so billig
wie nie
man nennt vielleicht schon das gemüse
des armen mannes hier großer aufreger im
netz mariniertes nackensteak von aldi
600 gramm für 199 alte bauernregel ist
das fleisch schon voller maden musst du
es in marinade baden und wenn sie jetzt
fragen wie geht das über ein von fleisch
für unter 2 euro
ganz einfach mit ausbeutung und
tierquälerei
deutschland wartet immer noch auf ein
staatliches tierwohl label seit jahren
da würde dann drauf stehen wie schlecht
es dem tier ging was da gerade auf ihrem
garten krematorium wurzelt schweine nur
ein beispiel schweine artgerecht halten
heißt unter anderem in spielzeug geben
das ist doch kein leben hier ist einfach
nur ekelhaft das ist das spielzeug für
das neue tirol siegel der
bundesregierung ja gut aber was für
spielzeug sollen einem schwein ergeben
eine playstation was nicht vor wenn wir
uns ehrlich machen müssen wir zugeben
massentierhaltung ohne tierquälerei gibt
wahrscheinlich nicht label hin oder her
und billiges fleisch gibt es hier nur
dank billiger bulgaren und rumänen in
vielen schlachtbetrieben sind 80 bis 90
prozent leiharbeiter oder menschen mit
werkverträgen osteuropa angestellt bei
subunternehmen von tönnies oder
westfleisch seit letztem sommer haften
die zwar theoretisch für ihre
subunternehmer
es wird aber in der praxis so gut wie
gar nicht kontrolliert da leben
teilweise acht menschen in einem mit
kakerlaken verseuchten raum die gute
nachricht aufs klo trauen sich die
kakerlaken nicht mehr offiziell kriegen
diese armen menschen mindestlohn dafür
werden aber ohne ende über stunden
einfach nicht bezahlt und wer sich
beklagt fliegt sofort raus denn diese
arbeiter haben keine rechte ja auch
deswegen kann in europa keiner mit
deutschen dumpingpreisen konkurrieren
inzwischen und das ist wirklich ein
hammer
inzwischen sind wir sogar in der lage
fleisch herzustellen das gar keines mehr
ist
das separatoren fleisch wird aus
schlachtabfälle
hergestellt in einem separator werden
die knochen regelrecht ausgedrückt es
entsteht ein brei der laut gesetz nicht
mehr fleisch genannt werden darf
ja weil es kein fleisch isst ein roter
glück 3 in dem sonst was sein könnte
da fällt mir ein was wurde eigentlich
wirklich aus kampf und chico nummer als
frage wahrscheinlich chicken mcnuggets
na ja das gibt post 130 tausend tonnen
separatoren fleisch werden bei uns in
deutschland jedes jahr hergestellt
70.000 tonnen separatoren vielleicht
bleiben im land und jetzt kommt der clou
in welchen fleischprodukten die am ende
landen das weiß keiner
und der gesetzgeber hat offenbar keine
lust dass nachzuverfolgen
es gibt so viele zutaten die fleisch
noch billiger machen wasser zb in die
wurst kommt nach reichlich wasser und
ein protein pulver schlacht blut das die
wasser zugabe verdeckt sodass es bei
einer kontrolle nicht auffliegt der
verbraucher kauft im grunde genommen
schnittfestes wasser ja schnittfestes
wasser oder wie man den holland sagt
tomaten
ja und wasser ist doch angeblich so
gesund sagen alle
damit müssten wir eigentlich werbung
machen für jeden tag an seine grenzen
geht muss viel trinken mindestens drei
liter am tag darum deutsche post den
dienst gibt dem körper das wasser das er
braucht ob beim yoga
[Musik]
wurde auf dem weg zur arbeit deutsche
post meerwasser hat nicht mal wasser
[Musik]
deutsche post so gesucht
gerade bei diesem wetter ist es sehr
wichtig ein prima wurst löscher die
neuesten trends der grillsaison
natürlich auch ein großes thema in
unseren service sendungen im deutschen
fernsehen herzlich willkommen zu volle
kanne fleisch mit sebastian buchbar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
51 spezial sebastian pufpaff unser
heute-show grillmeister ein pulverfass
hinten die grill trends 2018 ja
dieselben wie 2017 viel und billig
billig muss ist sein pass auf beim
discounter die num stegner
was haben wir denn da brewster fleisch
mit ganzen pusteln
da ist die verpackung teurer als das
fleisch und leckerer aber zwischen wird
welche morgen schicke ich noch eine vase
an meine schwiegermutter guck mal die
gott letzt sind das perfekte
verpackungsmaterial weil die kost nix
hier für dich und sage mir dass mit dem
vielen wasser im fleisch das stört sie
nicht nein das nutze ich doch besser auf
mein grill
das schätzen hier das hatten eingebauten
abwasseranschluss so mit dem wasser was
jetzt hier aus der wurst sucht kann ich
doch noch super hier die blumen gießen
oder vielleicht eine außendusche
betreiben oder was weiß ich ist das dvi
oder bei jesus haben alle gesagt auch
kummer kann hier aus wasser wein machen
wird deutschen wir machen aus wasser
wurst aber da klatscht keiner das sage
ich aber busacca dankeschön auf
wiedersehen
o
die kollegen von frontal21 haben gerade
versucht die billigste wurst der welt zu
machen
die wurst besteht zu 46 prozent aus
separatoren fleisch 27 prozent wasser
und nur 18 prozent fleisch und speck für
hervorragende qualität zeichnet die deg
unsere gepanschte wurst mit silber aus
und dafür gab es eine silbermedaille ja
gold ging leider eine wurst aus sägemehl
und bauschaum ja aber hier der frontal
21 megawatt total geschockt vom erfolg
seiner wurst eigentlich entsetzt mich
dass so ein bisschen
wir haben wirklich will ich dieses wort
verwenden das scheiße genommen das war
ja keine wurst habe ich gesagt ja hätten
sie mal die chance genommen das wäre
gesünder als reparaturen fleisch ja das
ist nämlich getrennt wir basteln uns
unser eigenes grillgut ich hab da mal
was eigenes für die grillsaison 20 18
kreiert kummer profis fleisch später das
ist ein rindersteak das habe ich aus
rouge wein und pangasius zusammengeklebt
und ich nehme das jetzt einfach
dreierlei vom tier noch probiert lang
nein nein oder für unsere kleinen
naschkatzen wunderbar hofs gesichts
wurst mit echten auch mit echten autos
sind dort die ganzen vitamine
warum muss denn unser fleisch immer
billiger werden ja muss muss den ganzen
kohle geht doch für den grill drauf hier
das baby das kostet mich 25 und ich die
kohle dafür ausgeben bleibt ja nichts
mehr für gutes fleisch übrig ich musste
sogar das auto meiner frau verkaufen
wenn man die rolle hat geheult iss
gekreuzt seehundbaby echt nervig echt
nervig nein nein aber ich sage immer du
schenkt dir das leben tränen weg einfach
bausparen ein
wer ist er jetzt ein rumäne
den kriegs umsonst dazu wenn es ein
riesen grill kaufs der wendet für mich
die würstchen ja billiger also geht es
mir als ob ich das noch mache sie hallo
da ist sebastian popp gemeinsamen der st
[Applaus]